What would happen if humankind became extinct
at any moment?
I bet that, among you, lovers of the post-apocalyptic
genre will have already foretasted this scenario,
whether it be by a nuclear winter, a giant
tidal wave as in Roland Emmerich's 2012 or
an unstoppable pandemic as in The Last of
Us.
The result, however, would be similar: ruined
buildings devoured by climbing plants, streets
occupied by car wrecks, animals and stores
pillaged.
A Fallout-like atmosphere, which writer Alan
Weisman describes in his essay The World Without
Us.
After all, it’s easy to imagine a completely
abandoned urban setting.
That’s what we are talking about today:
ghost towns.
They can be found everywhere, there are intact
ones and crumbling ones, and as we’ll see
shortly, their origins are indeed varied.
For American writer Lambert Florin, a ghost
town is "a ghostly semblance of what it itself
used to be."
That is why my first thought goes to Pryp"jat,
in the Ukrainian oblast of Kiev, evacuated
on April 28, 1986, the day after the well-known
Chernobyl nuclear disaster.
To date, radiation levels have stabilized
thanks in part to the new protective arch
surrounding the reactor.
To the point that the site attracts tourists
from all over the world thanks to the famous
ferris wheel and structures that have remained
literally forty years old.
Well, Pryp"jat leads the way for us to talk
about the first reason why a city should be
abandoned: a disaster.
This expanse of ash, sand and gutted dwellings
surrounded by tropical nature is-or rather,
was-Plymouth, the capital and main port of
entry to the island of Montserrat, a British
overseas possession located in the Lesser
Antilles archipelago.
To the south rises the Soufrière Hills, a
volcano just over 1,000 meters high that had
been dormant for centuries until it erupted
on several occasions beginning in July 1995,
flooding a large area of the island, including
the capital, with debris and pyroclastic flows.
Two years later, on June 25, 1997, a new devastating
eruption destroyed 80 percent of Plymouth,
burying it under ash.
The volcanic material consolidated to the
point that it became unremovable except with
the help of explosives or bulldozers, which
was impractical given the cost.
Therefore, after the British Navy ship, HMS
Liverpool, had evacuated the inhabitants to
other islands including Antigua and Guadeloupe,
most of them, chose to emigrate to the UK
or to Brades, the new de facto capital, now
the seat of administrative offices.
Officially, the capital still remains Plymouth,
awaiting the completion of the Little Bay
port in the northwest.
And what to do with a wasteland in the meantime?
Montserrat's government has clear ideas.
In 2016, then-Premier Donaldson Romeo declared,
"we have learned to live with the volcano
[...], it’s time to convert ash into money."
A metaphor?
Well, not so much.
As early as 2010, trucks and bulldozers had
begun removing sand from the so-called exclusion
zone, that is the inaccessible area-in Plymouth,
to sell it on the international market as
construction material.
The volcano itself has also come in handy,
so much so that between 2012 and 2017 the
island's government drilled three wells for
geothermal energy extraction with financial
help from the British Crown and wants to build
a fourth facility by 2024 right in the exclusion
zone.
This has coincided with the advent of tourists
and lovers of apocalyptic scenarios, who are
interested in what is now called "the Pompeii
of the Caribbean."
And from the combo of vacations and natural
disasters...here comes a ghost resort.
It’s Villa Epecuén, a land of architectural
skeletons, rotten trees, abandoned luggage
and wreckage of all kinds, which remained
submerged for a quarter of a century and resurfaced
only when the waters began to recede in the
summer of 2009.
Beginning in 1921, the area, some 600km from
Buenos Aires, began to be occupied by vacation
homes, stores, clubs, and luxury hotels, and
by the 1970s, the huge flow of tourists, attracted
by the healing properties of Lake Epecuen's
waters, brought the picturesque spa town to
accommodate a population of more than 5,000.
Everything seemed to be going well, until
in November 1985, a sudden drop in atmospheric
pressure generated a so-called sessa phenomenon,
that is, a periodic wave motion, in the lake.
The latter broke the embankment built in 1978
to protect the village, and before long the
area disappeared under 3 meters of water,
which then rose to 10 in 1993.
The drought of 2009 uncovered some of the
salt-bleached trees and structures, and among
the few still intact, a magnificent slaughterhouse
built by Argentine architect Francisco Salamone
stands out.
But there is a second reason that can lead
a city to mutate into a ghost town: the anticipation
of some disastrous event.
Do you know Mel Gibson's The Passion of the
Christ?
The movie was shot in Craco, an ancient, now
uninhabited medieval village in southern Italy,
Matera province.
First a huge landslide in 1963 that forced
the inhabitants to move downstream to Craco
Peschiera, then a flood in 1972 that prevented
the repopulation of the old town, and finally
the Irpinia earthquake in 1980 transformed
the village into a tourist attraction and
valuable movie set.
The same happened to the Irish island settlement
of Great Blasket, inhabited for centuries
by a small community that reached 200 people
in the early 20th century but was evacuated
permanently by the government in November
1953 because of increasingly extreme weather
conditions.
Fear of some unpleasant event has also reached
the Indonesian authorities.
The capital Jakarta is set to sink under water
by 2050, and this is due to the fact that
the megacity, already washed by the Java Sea,
rests on swampy ground traversed by as many
as 13 rivers.
It should come as no surprise that, due to
frequent flooding, in 2019 the local government
announced the construction of a new administrative
and political center, Nusantara, to be built
1,300 kilometers away on the island of Borneo.
Of course, this move, with an estimated cost
of $32.4 billion, brings with it objections
of various kinds, from the choice of name
for the new capital to the environmental issue
related to the deforestation of an area rich
in wildlife and rainforests.
But, for our purposes, it will be interesting
to observe the process of Jakarta's transition
from an overcrowded city housing 10 million
people into a ghost town.
On closer inspection then, what defines an
abandoned town is also a sudden change in
pre-existing economic conditions.
Those human settlements that arise as a result
of the industrial and demographic development
of a given area, such as around a factory
system or a mine, take the name “boomtown”.
Think of urban centers such as Manchester
and Liverpool, which arose during the Industrial
Revolution, or Kiruna, in Lapland, created
in 1900 by the Swedish kingdom to exploit
the nearby mine, which today supplies 80 percent
of the iron mined in Europe.
In the 1970s, as the mine expanded both above
and below ground, several neighborhoods in
the town were cleared and incorporated into
the expanding site.
After all, this is also the inevitable fate
of any village in the proximity of any deposit.
At the moment, the swedish government, in
order to prevent the prosecution of excavation,
which is already responsible for several landslides
in the ground and collapse of structures,
from endangering the safety of the inhabitants,
is implementing an ambitious - and expensive
- plan to physically move and reassemble elsewhere
some 3,000 structures, 65 percent of the buildings
in the entire town.
And what happens if the activity around which
a boomtown revolves suddenly ceases?
The example of the California town of Bodie
is illuminating.
We are in the areas bordering the Sierra Nevada
mountain range, where huge amounts of gold
were discovered beginning in the second half
of the 1800s (eighteen hundreds).
In 1859, a man named William or Wakeman S.
Bodey discovered a rich gold deposit about
16 kilometers from Monoville and there founded
Bodie, a modest town of just a few houses,
about 20 miners and almost irrelevant mining
activity.
This was because news of the discovery didn’t
spread far and took a back seat to the rapid
development of the huge Comstock Lode mines
in Virginia City and Aurora.
When these deposits were later exhausted,
Bodie experienced its moment of glory, coming
to be home to some 10,000 inhabitants between
1879 and 1880, dozens of saloons, brothels,
opium dens, and a small Chinatown, eventually
earning its reputation as "shooters town",
because of the frequent gunfights on the city
streets.
In the early 1900s mining began to decline,
and the mine closed its doors for good in
1913, leading to a rapid decline in profits,
until even the Bodie and Benton Railroad slowly
became unused.
The 50-kilometer rail line that, linking Bodie
to Mono Mills, ensured the mining town a steady
supply of lumber.
A series of adverse circumstances then led
residents to abandon the area in 1942, and
since 1962 Bodie has been a tourist attraction
in a state of "arrested decay," consisting
of dusty wooden buildings, wrecked Chevrolets
and rusting electric generators.
The same fate happened to many other outposts
that sprang up during the gold rush period.
But don't think that places devoted to various
mining activities escaped it.
The most problematic case is surely that of
Wittenoom, a former mining town in Western
Australia that has earned the unpleasant nickname
of "the most contaminated site in the southern
hemisphere."
In fact, the 20,000 people who lived there
were evacuated in 1978 because the mining
of crocidolite, the deadliest type of asbestos,
from 1943 to 1966 contaminated the soil, led
to the deaths of hundreds of people and increased
the risk of developing respiratory diseases
and cancers.
And over time, efforts to clean up and remove
3 million tons of toxic waste haven’t produced
the desired results.
An exclusion zone of 50 thousand hectares
of land is mentioned, but according to the
Australian government, the estimate could
be even worse.
Another deserted place is Kolmanskop, in southern
Namibia, a German architectural-style settlement
located on that portion of the Namib desert
that the German government in the early 1900s
classified as a "Sperrgebiet"- reserved area
- dedicated to diamond exploration.
In 1954 the diamonds ended and with them,
so did the mining.
Today, the desert has reclaimed its dominance
over houses, dance halls, casinos and even
Africa's first tramway.
Then taking a huge leap northward in latitude,
we find a very unique boomtown: we are talking
about Pyramiden, an old Swedish outpost dating
back to 1910 located in the Norwegian archipelago
of Svalbard and intended for coal production.
It was donated to the Soviet Union in 1927,
becoming the second Russian outpost on the
larger island of Spitsbergen, along with the
Barentsburg outpost.
This small 2-square-kilometer urban center,
operating under the control of Soviet mining
giant Arktikugol, was home to a community
of Russian miners for decades, and its 60
km of mine shafts continued to operate until
the early 1990s.
But reduced production combined with the costs
and logistics required to maintain such a
settlement in such a prohibitive location
led to its final closure in 1998.
Coal mining was also conducted on Hashima,
also called Gunkanjima, literally "warship
island", because of the distinctive shape
given to it by the concrete and steel buildings
there, and located about 20 kilometers away
from the port of Nagasaki, Japan.
In 1959, an area of just 6.5 hectares came
to house 5259 people, recording the highest
population density in history to date.
Not bad for a coal mine on the water that
closed its doors forever in 1974, when Mitsubishi
decided to focus on oil as an energy source.
Another remarkable ghost village is surely
Fordlandia, lost in the Amazon rainforest.
The birthplace of this town was, in 1928,
Henry Ford himself, who had decided to look
there for a source of cheap latex to bypass
the Sri-Lanka rubber monopoly maintained by
Britain, securing a direct and alternative
source of material for making tires.
This would contain the production costs of
the new Model A cars.
The investment wouldn’t only have economic
but also social significance, because it carried
with it Ford's desire to perform what was
later called "a work of civilization," aimed
at "helping to develop that wonderful and
fertile land."
Good intentions, however, had to contend with
the difficulty of standardizing the cultivation
of rubber trees, because planting them too
close together made them exposed to disease
and pests.
In addition, the chosen site made it difficult
to transport raw materials and facilitated
water stagnation, an ideal environment for
the spread of malaria.
To make matters worse, despite the high salaries,
worker discontent due to the rigid work rhythms
that followed assembly-line philosophies resulted
in revolt in December 1930.
In the end Fordlandia was all talk no action,
as in 1945 Ford's grandson was forced to sell
off the land to Brazil to cut down the rising
costs the company was facing.
At that time, World War II had come to an
end.
We all know about D-Day don't we?
The Normandy landings, which took place on
June 6, 1944 on the French coast.
According to the British, Operation Overlord
wouldn’t have been possible without Tyneham,
a small fishing village in Dorset that "died
for England."
A year before the landings, in 1943, the British
government confiscated it to allow Allied
forces to train on terrain considered similar
to what they would find upon arrival on the
continent.
Even if Churchill assured residents that they
would be able to return to their homes when
hostilities ceased, in 1948, with the Cold
War looming, it was decided to prioritize
defensive needs and so the state took over
Tyneham once and for all.
Today the village is owned by the Ministry
of Defense and is part of the Lulworth firing
ranges, which is why the area can only be
visited by tourists by special permit.
Moving to the other side of the English Channel,
four days after the Normandy landings, on
June 10, 1944, a battalion of 200 Nazi soldiers
rounded up the inhabitants of the small village
of Oradour-Sur-Glane under the guise of a
simple identity check and carried out a massacre,
burning alive 642 people including nearly
200 children and setting fire to houses, barns
and garages.
The real motivation for the massacre was the
kidnapping of an SS commander near Limoges,
about 20 kilometers away.
Of this ghostly place, today you would find
only crumbling buildings and a museum commemorating
the tragic event.
And indeed, unfortunately, war is one of the
main generators of ghost towns, either directly
or indirectly, by simple cruelty or military
interests.
Take the case of Varosha, once a booming tourist
district of the Cypriot city of Famagusta,
which at its peak was home to 39,000 residents
and which, after the invasion of Cyprus by
the Turkish military in July 1974, became
home to decaying buildings and crumbling hotels
cradled by a desolate beach.
In fact, in the aftermath of the invasion,
the local Greek Cypriot population fled, and
since then, no one has set foot there again,
except the Turkish military of course, since
today the area belongs de facto to the Republic
of Turkey.
In late 2020, however, the Turkish government,
which is pressing for international recognition
of Northern Cyprus, announced an initiative
to revive the old tourist town, until recently
unoccupied and classified as a military zone.
In one year, some 400,000 civilians would
visit it, and last October Ersin Tatar, president
of the self-proclaimed Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus, announced that Varosha would
also house public buildings.
And there you have it, depending on the interests
of the moment, beyond tourism, one can imagine
that a ghost town could be repopulated and
return to full operation.
Then we have the phenomenon of ghost towns
in China, which is quite unique.
Let me explain.
Let's consider Kangbashi, in China's Inner
Mongolia Autonomous Region, about 560 kilometers
west of Beijing.
It’s part of Ordos Prefecture, which has
a total population of 2 million, and together
with the urban core of Dongsheng is one of
the two largest municipalities.
The original plan was to build a boomtown
capable of housing one million people--a number
later scaled back to 300,000 (three hundred
thousand)--most of whom would work in the
nearby coal mines.
To be precise, the idea was to make Kangbashi
the new administrative center of Ordos Prefecture,
and government offices, medical facilities
and schools would be relocated to nearby Dongsheng.
To be precise, the idea was to make Kangbashi
the new administrative center of Ordos Prefecture,
and government offices, medical facilities,
and schools would be relocated to nearby Dongsheng.
The reality we are witnessing today is that
the new and expanding town is not quite empty,
but rather in 2016 boasted a substantial daytime
population, 100000 people of whom 80 percent
were full-time residents.
Not a bad result when compared to Chinese
housing standards.
Even so, photos show us endless rows of buildings
with no apparent sign of human life.
This is because there is a real culture of
real estate investment in China, due to the
widespread belief that this is the best way
to generate and preserve wealth.
What on the surface might look like derelict
cities are instead simply unoccupied, then
filled with new housing units purchased as
investments, also made by taking advantage
of government benefits, and remaining unoccupied
by owners or tenants.
Think that in all of China there are about
50 municipalities that are practically unoccupied
in proportion to their housing capacity, which
translates into 50 million homes without tenants,
according to reports by the South China Morning
Post.
The problem is that the housing sector is
a pillar of China's economy, worth about a
quarter of all the country's economic output.
Some believe there is a housing market bubble,
that is, a phenomenon of rising house prices,
which could collapse and bring the entire
national economy into the abyss.
Financial uncertainty is already affecting
Evergrande, one of the real estate development
giants, which has debts of $300 billion and
has about 1.6 million unsold apartments.
This is the result of decades of failed urban
planning projects, the highest expression
of which is the $9 billion theme park left
to rot in the city of Lu'an, located 500km
west of Shanghai, along with an electric car
factory that never went into operation.
And there you have it, the genesis of a post-apocalyptic
scenario...even before an apocalypse.
Despite everything, Xi Jinping's entourage
continues to commission ambitious urban projects
such as Xiong'an, a new, futuristic, hyper-technological
urban area southwest of Beijing, and all we
have to do is wait to see if the Communist
Party's vision will bear fruit or prove unsuccessful.
Another matter that is unclear to me is related
to Naypyidaw, the capital of Myanmar since
November 6, 2005.
The "king's residence"-that is the meaning
of the name-is located in the middle of the
jungle, is six times the size of New York
City, cost four billion dollars, has eight-lane
roads, luxury hotels, thirty government buildings
protected by a ditch, a giant golden pagoda,
and four huge golf courses.
Spectacular, on the surface.
I wonder, however, where its lifeblood is,
since it can't get to a million inhabitants.
The most certain thing at the moment is that
the former capital Yangon, which is about
300km away, remains the de facto cultural
and spiritual center of the country, making
the glitzy Naypyidaw a mere white elephant.
Oh I forgot, at least those huge roads were
used for an episode of Top Gear, that's something.
And with this last example we have come to
the end of our journey of discovery of grim
and peculiar places.
I'm sure I've forgotten many other ghost towns.
So, let me know what other places you think
are worthy of inclusion within this spooky
list.
Thank you all for your attention and we’ll
see you in the next video.
Ciao!